having now gotten their first glimpse of
Despicable me4 fans are left wondering
just how time in this Animated World
works exactly it seems to pass for some
and stay frozen for others the first
trailer for Despicable me4 is now
dropped giving fans a taste of the
minion Madness to come this summer while
the clip doesn't give away too much
about the plot it nevertheless promises
the same spy style Antics Charming
family Dynamics and zany comedy that
audiences have come to know and love
over the animated franchise's 14 years
of box office domination one of the most
interesting developments in the Spore Mi
4 involves Gru and Lucy's new baby Gru
junor something is missing this guy
there's my boy his introduction is
certain to be a new source of adorable
Mayhem and heartwarming moments as the
infant learns to bond with grow but for
long time fans the baby's inclusion also
opened up a perplexing question about
the Despicable Me franchise as a whole
one reditor was among the many viewers
asking this is the fourth movie and KW
has a baby now so why are those girls
not aging they look the exact same as
they did in the first movie it's
unlikely that fans would have such a
problem with the lack of Aging of Gru
are dubed daughters Margot Edith and
Agnes had grun not had a bouncing baby
boy but now that the family has welcomed
its newest member things are more
confusing than ever another redditor
observed giving Gru and Lucy a baby but
not a up the girls is crazy laughing my
ass off over on X formerly known as
Twitter a user compared the odd choice
to characters in The Dragon Ball
Universe saying four movies in and the
girls haven't aged up they got the Goten
and Trunks treatment the decision to
give grew a baby while leaving his
daughters the same age has some fans
trying to grasp the logistics of the
Despicable Me Universe describing seen
the trailer as a mind-bending moment
another ex user asked how's Gru got a
kid and and those girls haven't age
today what's the timeline of these
movies if the events of the Despicable
Me movies actually took place in real
time then the fourth movie would occur 7
years after the last adventure meaning
that the girl should have grown up quite
a bit however fans have determin that
the franchise's timeline doesn't match
the real world one such fan on X
suggested of grw junor the kids only a
few months old a year tops throwing in
pregnancy I'd say were only 18 to 24
months after the last film have also
theorized that 2013 supic me to takes
place a year after the 2010 original if
that same logic is applied to Despicable
me3 then it's not too much of a stretch
to buy into the series taking place
within a 5 to 10e time frame while some
fans are struggling to rub their heads
around the age of Gru's daughters others
don't see such a reason to sweat over
the matter in a franchise full of
over-the-top villains crazy gadgets and
Goofy yellow goons it's safe to chalk up
such lingering questions to good old
cartoon logic one redditor compared how
the characters in Despicable Me age or
don't to another famous animated family
writing audiences aren watching these
movies to see the characters grow up
with the viewer it's the exact same as
The Simpsons where we know what to
expect without any needless changes oh b
cartoons don't have to be 100%
realistic nevertheless it closes the
door to a potential opportunity for the
Despicable Me to defy expectations
another redditor argued even that the
first one was genuinely very emotional
and heartfelt and was about him becoming
a dad instead of all their stuff with
Lucy and a new baby they could have so
easily done a sillier version of a Toy
Story style kids growing up and dad has
to accept it type thing across a few
films what makes Gru's daughters seeming
to stay the same age so frustrating is
that it hampers their development as
characters and their relationship with
Gru since the first film saw them turn
the on fainus grew into a loving father
the girls haven't had as much presence
Within the franchise aiding them up and
having BR deal with the difficulties
that come with parenting pre-teens could
have given the sequel an amount of heart
that would surely surprise kids and
parents alike it's unlikely that such
lingering questions will deter viewers
from seeing despicable me4 but it will
certainly keep some scratching their
heads until its release on July 3rd
[Music]